non-minimalists
this is from the relationship with
people
chapter it's my favorite chapter in the
book so in the book we talk about
healing the seven essential
relationships in our life we talk about
some virtues we talk about how to
understand
other people and and ryan and i go into
depth about
appreciating people respecting people
etc some sort of virtues that are in our
life but then
there are these other things that we
perceive to be virtuous
in our society but we like to argue that
they are
overrated virtues these are called the
13 overrated virtues this is from page
275.
now that we've surveyed the most
pertinent qualities of worthwhile
relationships
we must also consider the virtues we've
been acculturated to believe
are noble but are often overrated
first one is loyalty
yes it is important to be loyal to loved
ones
but loyalty alone is typically misguided
and may even degrade your relationships
by creating a smoke a smoke screen
between
rationality and reality being loyal is
fine but loyalty at the expense of
integrity
is detrimental to a relationship tk
let's talk about loyalty for a second
because quite often in many cultures we
we hold it up as like the number one
virtue
so much so that we sometimes get blinded
by either being loyal or the need for
loyalty
unearned loyalty from other people and
sometimes we manipulate the people in
our lives
through unfounded appeals to loyalty
come on man we grew up together yeah
we're family
we're family we we have dna
commonalities we went to school together
how long have i been knowing you and
it's like whoa whoa whoa
there's nothing about me having known
you for 10 years
or you having grown up in the same
neighborhood as me
that in and of itself means that i need
to give you whatever you're asking or i
need to make whatever sacrifice you're
making it's kind of like when people say
things like
yeah i went to high school with tom
hanks yeah i went to high school with
george clooney it's like okay that's
great that y'all went to the same school
but there's nothing about going to the
same school that means that you have
the same destiny the same lifestyle the
same discipline
so to think yeah man that could have
been me me and george clooney went to
the same school no that couldn't have
been you right
because george clooney didn't make it as
an actor because he grew up in that
neighborhood and went to that school
it's because he applied himself to a
kind of discipline
that other people at that school didn't
apply to it didn't apply in their lives
so anyway it's a it's a tool that we can
use to manipulate others and sometimes
we might manipulate people this way with
the best of intentions
we may not even know that we're doing it
and so um i think it's not just a
one-way thing it's not just something
that people do to us but we do it to
them as well
yeah yeah i think about uh
man i'm trying to decide if i guess it's
the private podcast so
um this was years ago they were visiting
in montana with
some other family members but they're on
the couch and they're having this
conversation
says something like oh i just i love
that we're family because that means i
can just talk to you however i want and
you have to love me
and i'm like you guys are insane like we
use
this we use this idea of loyalty to take
advantage
to to hold people to a different
standard when really
you really should use that that family
at to put some
to treat someone better like to go out
of your way yeah because i even said
like hey look man like i'm telling you i
have friends who treat me better than
you do he's like yeah but we're family
i'm like yeah
so doesn't that doesn't it make sense
that you would use the excuse of family
to treat me even better than the way my
friends treat me
and like it and it did click with them
um but yeah it's unfortunate that
we use that as leverage it's almost like
the same thing when
uh my dad had his painting and wallpaper
business
we would be at someone's home and
there's there's this weird thing that we
could totally
totally dive into a little bit more if
you want to but as jehovah's witnesses
when you meet another jehovah's witness
like there's this like instant
connection like oh you're jehovah's
witness
so we'd be at someone's house and that
we would find out like oh like i see you
know
some literature like oh you show us
witnesses yeah i'm a jehovah's oh yeah
me too cool
oh man what about what about hooking me
up with a discount since we're you know
we're both brothers
we're brother and sister whatever and
and my dad used to always say like no
why don't you pay me more because
we're both drove as one and says yeah
you should probably pay me double wow
yeah and it's and it's just funny i like
we we don't use these connections we
don't use the thing like loyalty for the
good
we use it to like gain something from
someone else when it's it really should
be an excuse to give not gain
wow yeah you know there there is a good
sentiment that
i i think lies at the heart of a healthy
understanding of loyalty and that is
there are some things in life that are
valuable enough to not be subject to
convenience
because we're not always in the mood to
do the right thing
sometimes our feelings make us say
i don't feel like showing up in ways
that i know
my value system demands me to show up i
i or or like some of the calls that we
that we receive
i i don't feel like giving up this thing
that's holding me back
i know i need to do it but i don't feel
like it right and loyalty is getting at
the idea that
you need to develop the habit of being
faithful to things
even when those things are not easy to
do but loyalty gets misplaced
when we ground it in people rather than
principles
the thing that you're to be loyal to are
your principles
and the process of continually upgrading
those principles in light of further
knowledge
not the fact that we went to high school
together right yeah like the whole
example you use at george clinton it's
like the only connection that that
person has with george clooney is the
high school that's it
there's no other connection and we want
to draw other connections but i i just
want to
like call out here that these things
that these 13 things we wrote about
there's no value judgment on these
things in the sense that these 13
virtues
aren't bad things to have in your life
the problem
and what we call it it's problems when
we overrate them we rely on them too
much to be this
good person yes that's where that's
where the
that's where it gets to be a little bit
of a slippery slope um so loyalty is
great to be loyal to yourself yeah to be
loyal to your partner
i'm a little loyal to utk in a lot of
ways but it's not something that i'm
like well
the reason why tk and i have such a
great relationship is because no matter
what
we're loyal to each other yeah if you
find out that he killed your sister
right yeah but i got to be loyal to him
well then of course that's taking
loyalty too
far you ever notice that a lot of people
who follow loyalty dogmatically
are often the most bitter people expand
on that
i was attracted to that girl and
i laughed at every joke i listened to
her complain
when she complained to me i let her use
my truck so that she can move from one
apartment to the other i gave her so
much of my time and so much of my energy
and then when she didn't like me back i
got really angry and really bitter and
really resentful
you like that other guy who doesn't even
treat you well and i treat you good
as if your attractions to me
should be based on loyalty to the fact
that i have been
good to you right when people use
loyalty
as a negotiating tool in order to obtain
someone else's affection or approval it
always leads to bitterness if you're
going to be loyal to someone
only be loyal because that's consistent
with your true principles preferences
and priorities
not because you think they're going to
reward you with love
for being a nice person a good person a
humble person or whatever you think it
may be like
moral values are not there to make us
liked
they're there to make us better yeah
yeah i mean
another way to say that is a very common
saying of like give without the expect
the expectation of getting back and like
you're going to live such a better life
when you're giving
without that expectation but yeah i
think any time that you're expecting to
get
you're only doing something because you
expect to get something back yeah i
think that's where your equation comes
in
is loyalty grounded in expectation is
the express route to misery
oh man tweet that podcast sean come on
did you enjoy this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent
advertisement free